en fait c'est une grande efficacité hier
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
séance d'aujourd'hui conclut l'examen au
parlement du projet de loi portant
diverses dispositions de vigilance
sanitaire
compte tenu de la succession rapide des
étapes précédentes d'examen du texte par
les deux assemblées je pense que tout a
été déjà dit ou presque sur ce projet de
loi remet et le contexte sanitaire dans
lequel celui-ci s'inscrit
permettez-moi toutefois de rappeler que
les dispositions du texte sont
pleinement justifiées par la situation
sanitaire et son évolution prévisible
dans les prochains mois
nous en avons en effet pas terminé avec
l'épidémie de kovy 19 et nous devrons
faire face à de vrais risques de rebond
épidémique en france comme dans le reste
de l'europe
certains pays connaissent d'ailleurs une
dégradation préoccupante de leur
situation sanitaire qui rappellent si
cela était encore nécessaire qu'il
faudra collectivement rester mobilisés
vigilant au cours de la période à venir
devront en effet continuer à lutter
contre cette épidémie en poursuivant
toutes les actions nécessaires pour
protéger la santé de nos concitoyens
ainsi de la vaccination pour laquelle
nous devrons convaincre et accompagner
nos citoyens qui ne sont toujours pas
protégés en particulier les plus
vulnérables
nous ne devrons pas non plus relâcher
nos efforts pour la campagne de rappel
qui doit encore progresser pour
maintenir l'efficacité de la vaccination
à un niveau élevé niveau élevé de
protection et il en va de même pour
l'ensemble des mesures de freinage
permettant de limiter la circulation de
l'épidémie et c'est bien l'objet du
projet de loi que de permettre un
recours à ces outils qui ont pleinement
fait leurs preuves depuis plusieurs mois
permettez moi à cet égard de répondre à
deux critiques
que j'ai souvent entendu sur ce texte la
première c'est que ce projet de loi
serait un blanc seing donné au
gouvernement dans les prochains mois
privant le parlement de ses prérogatives
la prorogation 31 juillet prochain avait
pour conditions un dispositif renforcé
d'information du parlement c'est bien ce
que prévoit le texte par la remise d'ici
la mi février d'un rapport qui exposera
les mesures prises pour freiner
l'épidémie et qui justifiera le cas
échéant la nécessité de les maintenir
pour la période restante ses modalités
d'information l'assemblée nationale les
attraits significativement renforcée je
pense à la joue au sein du rapport
d'étape d'indicateurs sanitaires à la
remise d'un second rapport d'ici la mi
mai ou encore la production
d'information mensuel sur les mesures
prises et leur impact sur la situation
sanitaire
la formation pleine et entière du
parlement sera donc assurée dans les
prochains mois et ainsi que le ministre
des solidarités de la santé l'a rappelé
devant vous en première lecture le
gouvernement répondra présent si votre
assemblée souhaité en débattre que cela
soit en commission ou en séance
j'ajoute également que si nous étions à
mener compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire toujours a déclaré à nouveau
l'état d'urgence sanitaire sur tout ou
partie du territoire national
le parlement devrait vous le savez être
impérativement saisi mes chers collègues
pour autoriser la mise en oeuvre et le
la d'un mois
la seconde critique qui a souvent été
adressée à ce texte c'est qu'il
menacerait les libertés publiques et
entre entretiendrait un état d'exception
là encore cette critique est infondée
les prérogatives qu'il permettra de
mobiliser s'inscrivent dans un régime
juridique précis un régime juridique
exigeant qui restent inchangées et qui a
fait ses preuves pour concilier
l'objectif de protection de la santé
publique avec le respect des droits et
libertés constitutionnellement garantis
ce régime c'est vous en tant que
législateur qu'il avait défini puis
précisé instruits par l'expérience
acquise au fur et à mesure de la gestion
de l'épidémie les différentes mesures
prises dans ce cadre devront toujours
répondre aux exigences essentielles de
nécessité de proportionnalité dont le
respect est et demeure évidemment
placée sous le contrôle du juge
administratif y compris via des mesures
de référé d'urgence et comme vous le
savez mesdames et messieurs les députés
ce droit au recours a été demeure très
substantiellement exercée par les
requérants à l'issue des lectures
successives du projet de loi le texte
qui vous est soumis aujourd'hui est donc
un texte équilibré c'est un texte
pragmatique à venir je conclurai mon
propos en saluant l'engagement sans
faille de votre assemblée depuis bientôt
vingt mois afin de lutter au mieux
contre ce virus nul n'aurait pu imaginer
que nous aurions à discuter d'un 11e
projet de loi sur la gestion d'une
épidémie sans précédent dans notre
histoire moderne mais vous avez toujours
été au rendez vous pour y répondre en
tant que législateur y compris dans des
situations d'extrême urgence
grâce à votre soutien nous poursuivrons
dans la voie qui a été la nôtre depuis
le début de cette crise avec la
préoccupation constante d'assurer la
protection de la santé de nos
concitoyens dans les meilleures
conditions possibles je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à monsieur jean pierre pont rapporteur
de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
république
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des lois chers collègues nous
examinons aujourd'hui en lecture
définitive le texte équilibré et opérant
que l'assemblée nationale a adopté en
nouvelle lecture dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi
alors que le virus de la coved 19
s'installe durablement dans nos vies et
menacent à nouveau mon souci constant a
été de veiller tout au long des débats
au maintien de la stabilité et de la
président unité des outils de lutte
contre l'épidémie il s'agissait en
priorité de préserver leur caractère
adaptable et réactif dans un contexte
fragile où la situation sanitaire ne
s'améliorent plus et qu'on recommence à
se dégrader et d'ailleurs je rappellerai
quelques chiffres actuellement c'est
près de dix mille cas par jour en france
plus de mille personnes en réanimation
certains départements vont remettre le
masque à l'école et l'europe n'est pas
mieux loti puisque la grande bretagne la
belgique et les pays bas souffrent et
l'allemagne qui avec près de quarante
mille cas n'avait pas connu de tels
chiffres depuis décembre 2001
enfin le m s qui craint 500 mille décès
en europe d'ici quatre mois insiste donc
sur trois priorités qui doivent guider
notre action dans les prochains mois
maintenir notre vigilance collective
face au virus et surtout ne pas baisser
la garde
conforter les outils juridiques
désormais éprouvée qui permettent de
gérer une crise sanitaire durable faire
confiance aux autorités sanitaires qui
oeuvrent sans relâche dans cette lutte
depuis maintenant 18 mois
n'oublions pas que toute notre politique
depuis le mois de mars 2020 est guidé
par le seul objectif de protéger la
santé des français
nous n'en avons pas dévié et nous
garderons cette seule boule soldes comme
guide de notre action
c'est vrai que certains nous reprochent
une prolongation trop longues sans
revoyure en rappelant même que pendant
la grande guerre le parlement était
régulièrement informés
je rappe je rappellerai qu'en 1914 nos
soldats étaient partis pour quelques
mois et en fait seul a duré quatre ans
je rappellerai aussi que depuis 18 mois
c'est le dixième texte soit un texte de
moins tous les deux mois et nous nous
retrouvons
régulièrement très régulièrement pour ce
set contre cette maladie est d'ailleurs
aussi la présidente de la commission des
lois a récemment précisé que ces textes
ont occupé 25% du temps du travail de la
commission
quant à la revoyure elle est prévue est
promise mi février
j'aurais préféré qu'il n'y en aurait pas
voulu dire que la pandémie était loin de
nous mais je crains le contraire et nous
aurons un débat que certains appellent
pseudo-débats
peut-être et peut-être si je voulais
être provocateur
mes chers collègues nous écoutons notre
à porter et
recevoir à ces débats qui est intime et
de pseudo débat et si je voulais être
provocateur je dirais qu'il faut
peut-être le parallèle avec de pseudos
primaire ou de pseudo congrès mais je ne
serai pas provocateur et je ne saurais
pas
alors
mes chers collègues
nous sommes au début d'une longue
journée
chacun va passer toute la journée ici on
le sait bien mais en tout état de cause
il faut préserver nos forces donc nous
écoutons le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président alors
mesdames et messieurs monsieur le
ministre madame
madame la présidente
l'assemblée nationale monsieur le
ministre est fier de vous renouveler une
10e fois sa pleine confiance
disposés à niveau de tous les outils
juridiques pour ballack était toute à
l'heure maintenant écoutez monsieur pons
cette crise jusqu'au 31 juillet prochain
continuer d'en faire bon usage
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur j'ai reçu
de madame mathilde de panneaux et des
membres du bourg la france a soumis une
motion de rejet préalable déposé en
application d'un petit 91 alinéa 5 du
règlement avant de passer la parole à
madame panneau je précise que à la
demande du groupe de la france a soumis
sur cette motion de rejet préalable il y
aura un scrutin public le scrutin est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale et maintenant la présidente
panneaux à la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre collègues vous nous demandez
aujourd'hui les pleins pouvoirs pour
prolonger le pass sanitaire avec
l'éternel justification d autoritaire
c'est pour votre bien vous nous demandez
aujourd'hui d'accepter un régime
d'exception pendant huit mois et demi
sans aucune décision démocratique du
parlement avec pour vous seul le pouvoir
exorbitant d'activer ou de désactiver le
pass sanitaires à votre guise ou plutôt
selon le bon vouloir du président mais
là aussi française française c'est pour
votre bien le pass solitaire qui ne
devait jamais être étendue aux activités
du quotidien qui ne serait jamais un
droit d'accès qui différencie les
français qui ne devait être que
temporaire pourra donc être prolongée
pendant encore huit mois et demi et
pourquoi le 31 juillet 2022 on ne sait
pas ou plutôt l'on devine on sait si on
sait que vous pensez que l'élection prés
en ciel semble être pour vous une
formalité mais vous verrez le peuple
français aura tôt fait de vous rappeler
qu'une élection se noue ne se noue que
le jour du vote et que les 500 fortunes
de france qui ont doublé leur fortune
grâce à vous sont bien moins nombreuses
que les millions de personnes que vous
avez plongé dans la pauvreté dans la
précarité
oui c'est pour votre bien que des
millions de nos concitoyens continueront
d'être exclu du restaurant ou du bistrot
du cinéma de coin c'est roues du train
qu'une partie de la population
continuera de scanner à tout va une
autre partie de la population c'est pour
votre bien que continuera la gestion
sécuritaire de la santé publique même
s'il est vrai que contrainte n'a jamais
prouvé son efficacité et même pire a
démontré sa contre-productivité c'est
pour votre bien chers concitoyens que
les moyens humains et financiers que
réclament désespérément les soignants
attendront que la levée des brevets sur
les vaccins ne se fera pas la société du
roulement le pôle public du médicament
les purificateurs d'air n'en n'ont
d'alternative il n'ya pas vous
infantiliser les français et empêcher la
démocratie sanitaire dont nous avons
besoin mais si vous faites cela c'est au
nom de l'efficacité
la start up nation n'est jamais loin
avoue croire pour qu'une décision soit
bonne il faut qu'elle soit efficace et
donc prise rapidement par l'exécutif et
même le président de la république
exclusivement de préférence quand vous
nous présenter un texte sanitaires vous
veillez à ce qu'il ne ressorte intacte
et qu'aucune proposition amendements de
l'opposition ne vienne le ternir ces
l'immaculée conception revisité dans
cette affaire la démocratie sur et du
temps perdu voyez vous nous pensons au
contraire qu'une décision est bonne
parce qu'elle est prise collectivement
et que les cafouillages les mensonges
les couacs en tout genre ne sent pas
étranger au fait qu'une décision a été
prise en solitaire le passe à lithaire
lui-même regorge d'absurdité depuis
quatre mois que celui ci est mise en
place vous n'avez toujours pas expliqué
pourquoi il est requis pour s'asseoir à
une terrasse à moitié vite et pas au
sein de la restauration collective les
enfants n'ont pas besoin pour pratiquer
un sport dans le cadre scolaire en
revanche dans le même gymnase dans le
même vestiaire il leur en faut un s'ils
sont inscrits dans un club sportif
associatif pour ce qui est de son
obligation pour prendre le tgv est pas
le trop alors là vous nous livrer une
analyse anthropologique fouillé inédite
dans les trains les gens enlève beaucoup
leur masque mais pas dans le métro
disait madame la ministre tiens donc
d'où vient ce constat digne d'une étude
du cnrs sûrement pas d'une étude
empirique visiblement
l'examen de la nécessité ou non d'une
troisième dose de vaccin pour freiner
l'épidémie rend le pas salutaire
d'autant plus absurde il faudrait alors
l'étendre à l'obtention d'une troisième
dose le prolonger ainsi vous voulez
créer un pass sanitaire éternelle mais
surtout ce texte des roches de nouveau à
des principes fondamentaux pas de secret
médical les chefs d'établissement par
exemple pourront connaître qui parmi
leurs élèves sont vaccinés mais encore
pas de vaccin pas de travail pas de
vaccin pas d'allocations chômage pas de
vaccin pas de tests gratuits de
dépistage
quelle idée brillante à l'heure où le
taux d'incidence remonte sensiblement
alors quoi collègues allez vous
continuer longtemps à fracturer le pays
encore une fois le pas salutaire vous
donne bonne conscience en donnant une
illusion de sécurité le ministre de la
santé lui même a reconnu ici que
l'hôpital public elle est extrêmement
mal et ce depuis des années au moins il
reconnaît qu'il ya des déserts médicaux
que des soignants manque dans notre pays
qu'en gros il serait tributaire d'une
situation dont il n'est pas responsable
pourtant monsieur verront appliquer les
mêmes recettes qui aboutissent toujours
au même échec 4 milliards d'euros
d'économies sur le dos de l'hôpital
public depuis 2000 17-14 milices
supprimés dans 5700 d'hospitalisation
complète en 2020 schengen pour finir
l'autoritarisme sanitaire est le
contraire d'une politique et d'un
travail de conviction vite ma dose ou
d'octo l'ip ne constitue pas une
politique de santé publique une
véritable politique de santé publique
est une politique où il ya des humains
pour expliquer avec pédagogie sans
jugement ni culpabilisation mais non
avec vous comme d'habitude la matraque
et valables en tout temps et pour toute
chose nous continuerons à vous le
répéter plutôt que de vous en donnons
convaincu prenez-vous temps à vous même
les non convaincant et si vous n'osez
pas voter pas cette notion de rochers
nous saisirons dès cet après midi le
conseil constitutionnel sur ce texte
merci
je ne vois pas de demande de la
commission du gouvernement pour
s'exprimer avant les explications de
vote nous en venons donc maintenant aux
explications de vote explications de
vote n'a le temps mais sa collègue à les
explications de vote un monsieur
gouffier chars la parole
merci monsieur le président si
mes chers collègues je serais bref on a
bien compris que vous étiez content et
que vous aviez déjà en tête très
largement la future période électorale
nous avons pour notre part en tête la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et la
protection des françaises et des
français et la garantie du retour à la
vie normale que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui aussi nous voterons contre
cette motion de rejet merci
savignat la parole pour le groupe l'est
républicain
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur si ce texte est adopté tout à
l'heure dans cet hémicycle il le sera
par la majorité de cet hémicycle contre
la majorité parlementaire les français
ne veulent pas de ce dispositif tel
qu'il est nous vous avons proposé de le
construire nous vous avons proposé de
l'amendé et vous n'avez jamais rien
voulu entendre vous voudriez aujourd'hui
qu'on voulait se faire comme bon vous
voudrez faire dans l'avenir pour gérer
cette crise sanitaire alors que ce matin
pierre et paul ont pris le bus côte à
côte ils passent la matinée en classe
côte à côte ils mangeront côte à côte à
la cantine à midi cet après midi ils
iront à la gym ensemble ils rentreront
côte à côte dans le bus et ce soir à
l'heure du cours de judo paul ne pourra
pas y aller parce qu'il n'a pas de
passes sanitaires vous êtes capable de
ces aberrations et vous voudriez quand
vous l'êtes gérer la suite de la crise
il n'en n'est évidemment pas question
vous avez fait fi de tout ce que nous
avons proposé vous passer en force nous
voterons cette motion de rejet
madame florennes à la parole pour le
groupe modem
merci monsieur le président
avec cette motion de rejet il est clair
que les critiques qui sont faites sont
avant tout des postures politiques et
nous l'avons vu tout au long de ces
débats l'heure et la gravité du contexte
et et une ses postures sont
inappropriées dans l'eure à l'heure où
le contexte évidemment sanitaire vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre et
monsieur le maire à porter est grave
notre groupe l'a démontré lors de
l'examen de chacun des onze textes de
lutte contre la crise sanitaire nous
sommes déterminés à proposer un cadre
juridique adapté équilibré qui protège
les français et protège les libertés
ce texte de vigilance un d'iter
s'inscrit dans cette volonté nous sommes
déterminés à assurer le rôle bien et
entier du parlement pendant ces
différentes phases état d'urgence
sanitaire gestion de sortie de crise
sanitaire et maintenant comme nous
l'avons souhaité vigilance sanitaire
nous avons eu vrai dans ce sens sans
jamais faillir comme on a pu le dire
convainc pu le dire notamment les
ministres et le rapporteur tout au long
des prochains mois l'information du
parlement sera pleine et entière avec un
débat comme nous l'avions souhaité au
mois de février par ailleurs si l'état
d'urgence sanitaire était sanctionné il
ne pourrait pas être prolongée au delà
d'un mois sans l'accord du parlement
contexte mérite ces contextes mérite
autre chose que ses jeux et ses et ses
jeux etc électorat this je l' ai déjà
dit pour notre groupe ce qui est
important c'est de savoir si nous
voulons continuer à être responsable et
à protéger la santé des français nous
sommes déterminés à proposer un cadre
juridique nous l'avons dit et ce texte
là s'inscrit dans cette volonté nous
sommes également déterminés à assurer le
rôle du parlement comme ont pu le dire
le ministre et le rapporteur tout au
long des prochains mois cette
information sera faite donc non le
parlement n'est pas bafoués non la
démocratie n'est pas à museler nous
sommes là pour le prouver depuis 20 mois
et au sexe donc nous voterons contre mes
recettes mondiales
la parole est maintenant madame el hadj
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci monsieur le président
passe sanitaire dans un tgv pas de
passes sanitaire dans le métro même si
les bons des passes sanitaire en club
sportif pas de passes sanitaire en eps
bat salies terre à l'aide aux devoirs
pas de passes sanitaire en périscolaire
passe à lutter dans un café après une
réunion pas de passes sanitaires à la
messe pas sanitaire au restaurant pas de
passes sanitaires aux bureaux en open
space on n'y comprend rien personne n'y
comprend rien
deux tiers du parlement vous alerte mais
vous n'en avait que faire
vous nous parlez d'un dialogue mais
regardez le nombre d'amendements qui ont
été adoptés sur ce texte aucun patch
suspens y en a aucun j'appelle pas ça un
débat j'appelle bat un dialogue
j'appelle ça un monologue d opposition
qui dans une démarche responsable et
constructive essaye d'apporter leur
pierre à l'édifice vous alerter et de
quoi construire est face à nous un
silence assourdissant
nous disons non mais attendez on vous
fait déjà la grâce n'honore réjouissez
vous de vous laisser débattre de ce
texte mais enfin de quoi vous plaignez
vous dès qu'on vous dit qu'on n'est pas
d'accord vous nous dites vous êtes
irresponsables regarder le nombre de
morts les blessés comme si nous n'avions
que faire votre irresponsabilité en la
matière nous alertent
l'urgence ne justifie pas tout surtout
quand on n'est plus en situation
d'urgence parce que 18 mois après le
début de cette pandémie dix-huit mois
après la crise de mars 2020 aujourd'hui
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
nous ne sommes plus en situation
d'urgence comme vous semblez l'indiqué
nous sommes dans un régime de droit
commun et il est temps de renouer avec
on écoute ton épouse on s'écoute pour
toutes ces raisons collègues
un peu de respect à l'égard des uns et
des autres enfin
merci de conclure madame anna toutes ces
raisons nous voterons cette motion de
rejet ne vous en déplaise
la parole et prie monsieur houbron pour
le groupe agir ensemble
merci monsieur le président il n'y aura
pas de grande surprise puisque nous
avons déjà rejeté une motion de rejet
préalable il ya 48 heures et donc nous
renouvellerons ce vote simplement je
suis assez surpris de constater
peut-être l'absence de conscience de la
réalité des choses aujourd'hui les
données dont nous disposons
sont plus qu'inquiétantes et ça a été
rappelé par le directeur de l' oms pour
la zone europe qui craint un demi
million de morts sur la zone europe
d'ici à février
la crise n'est pas derrière nous la
crise est permanente elle est devant
nous et nous donnons aujourd'hui avec ce
projet de loi les outils au gouvernement
pour agir dans l'intérêt de la
protection de nos concitoyens et donc
c'est en responsabilité que nous
rejetterons cette motion de rejet que
nous voterons ce projet de loi
donne la parole le groupe u10
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur
je ne sais pas si c'est un pseudo débat
je ne sais pas s'il y a deux pseudos
primaire ou un pseudo congrès
en l'occurrence je sais une chose qui
n'est pas un pseudo c'est un président
de la république en campagne avec le
chéquier de la france en bandoulière et
qui à aucun moment d'ailleurs ne parle
aux français de la crise sanitaire on
n'entend plus emmanuel macron sur la
crise sanitaire alors que vous nous
demandez aujourd'hui
effectivement de prolonger des mesures
attentatoires aux libertés individuelles
nécessaires à la protection de la santé
de nos concitoyens et sur lequel il faut
effectivement un vrai débat
et pas ce que vous nous proposez depuis
quelque part le début de la crise
sanitaire qui consiste à dire laissez
nous prendre les mesures faites nous
confiance et on en reparle après le rôle
du parlement ça n'est pas celui là le
rôle du parlement c'est précisément
d'exercer ses fonctions
ces missions
de ne pas se dessaisir au profit de
l'exécutif sur des sujets aussi graves
et ça fait presque deux ans maintenant
que vous nous demandez texte à prétexte
de nous dessaisir de nos prérogatives
alors nous voulons le débat et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous ne voterons
pas la motion de rejet préalable
mais ce débat nous voulons la voir pour
vous exprimer notre opposition au texte
que vous nous présentez
merci la parole est un monsieur molac
pour le groupe liberté territoire
merci monsieur le président donc la
chambre haute a rejeté le texte et hier
en fustigeant le refus de négocier le
refus d'encadrer les mesures et
finalement si l'on se retrouve pour
discuter c'est toujours la même chose on
se retrouve finalement pour donner un
blanc seing au gouvernement sans
encadrer les mesures sans regarder ou
peut-être à posteriori avec un rapport
que nous donnerait le gouvernement où il
mettra évidemment ce qu'il veut de dents
donc c'est un véritable problème créé un
problème démocratique
l'impression que ça donne finalement
c'est que vous ne voulez pas discuter
des mesures parce que ça fait quand même
depuis mars 2020 que vous avez les
pleins pouvoirs et vous nous dites la
pandémie redouble bon alors on pourrait
se poser la question est ce que vous
avez fait les bons choix mais on en a
jamais discuté ici comme par hasard
puisque vous prenez toujours les bons
choix
visiblement on peut quand même se poser
des questions
et c'est bien dommage parce que le rôle
du parlement effectivement ses deux co
construire et vous n'avez jamais essayé
de construire en fait vous ne savez pas
véritablement où vous allez mais au lieu
de le dire et au lieu de construire
quelque chose ensemble faux dit non non
on continue et puis on verra bien je
suis désolé mais moi je suis pas là pour
vous donner un blanc seing donc je
voterai cette motion de rejet mais
l'appareil est maintenant madame solide
ruban pour la france est soumise
nous voilà réunis pour la énième et
dernier débat sur le passé ni terre
jeudi débat je devrais plutôt parler de
soliloque temps les remarques réflexion
interrogations suggestions des
oppositions ont été évincés élus des
déboutés pourtant ce dispositif est
plein de contradictions man fois évoqué
passe dans le restaurant pas la
restauration par it collé un
professionnel passe pour le rer pas pour
le train alors certes depuis monsieur
notre collègue balanant nous a éclairé
judicieusement on peut manger un
sandwich dans un wagon sncf pas dans les
rames de métro trêve de plaisanterie
cinq mois plus tard le contrôle se
resserre avec un surcroît d'absurdité et
d'inégalités les tests devienne payant
quand il s'agit d'un outil indispensable
pour la prévention on peut faire du
sport à l'école mais par l'association
pour ses loisirs on peut aller en
bibliothèque nationale et universitaire
mais pas en bibliothèque municipale et
même le secret des élèves est bafouée au
nom d'une d'un meilleur suivi pour de
l'épidémie mais comment y croire comment
y croire quand seuls les jeunes non
vaccinés seront susceptibles d'être
exclues d'une classe alors que les
vacciner peuvent aussi être contagieux
et alors que le doute subsiste sur la
pertinence du vaccin sur les jeunes en
terme de bénéfice risque pourtant
doctement on nous explique que se passe
c'est la liberté incroyable novlangue la
liberté de ne pas aller travailler pour
les infirmières les pompiers les
serveurs les cuisiniers la liberté de ne
pas avoir de loisirs et de ne pas
pouvoir circuler
la seule liberté que vous prenez c'est
avec nos libertés constitutionnelles
pour finir jose une hypothèse à une
question elle aussi laissée sans réponse
pourquoi vous arc bouté sur une
prolongation jusqu'au 31 juillet pour
éviter peut-être tout débat avant les
élections présidentielles tant il est
vrai pour vous la démocratie ça prend un
temps tout à fait inutile alors parce
que ce parce qu un sale se passe un
stade une société de contrôle sans
permettre le contrôle des défis des
livres mais nous voterons pour cette
motion monsieur wulfranc ultime orateur
avant le vote
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi une telle fébrilité dans les
rangs de la majorité à quelques minutes
de ce vote et bien tout simplement parce
que vous êtes face à une situation un
contrôle et de votre part une politique
sanitaire un contrôle et que vous avez
vous même nourrit pas votre politique
sanitaire notamment en matière
hospitalière
ce dont nous vous avons alerté depuis
des années et qui vous conduit
aujourd'hui à vous retrouver dans une
position de défiance vis-à-vis des
français les français au delà de votre
politique sociale au delà de votre
politique économique
ne sont pas en confiance par rapport à
votre gestion de la crise et cela vous
conduit à renforcer votre pratique
autoritaire cette pratique autoritaire
vous la conduisait jusqu'à ce matin vers
un vote attentatoire à la liberté des
français attentatoires également
attentatoires également un certain
nombre de nos principes constitutionnels
et vous vous installez le pays dans une
séquence
sanitaire qui va coïncider avec une
séquence électorale dans lesquelles vous
impliquer un cadre d'exception un cadre
d'exception à votre main et tout cela
tout cela bien évidemment et bien
inquiète au plus haut point l'opinion
publique dans ces conditions nous
voterons pour cette motion de rejet
préalable
merci donc les explications de bottes
sont intervenus chacun regagner sa place
le vote électronique a été annoncé
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats
votants 184 exprimé 183 majorité 92 pour
71 contre 119 donc la motion n'est pas
adoptée nous poursuivons nos travaux
et nous en venons à la discussion
générale la parole est un monsieur
gautier chat pour la république en
marche
avec les familles
très bien on l'amène en bretagne la
semaine prochaine
merci marc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant nous avons retrouvé une vie
normale ou quasi normale les restaurants
et les lieux de vie de nos quartiers ont
réouvert les musées les cinémas les
bibliothèques aussi on irait découvrent
la joie des découvertes et des échanges
nous avons pu retrouver le chemin de nos
activités sportives également la vie
reprend son cours depuis plusieurs mois
et la situation économique a retrouvé
son dynamisme d'avant mars 2020
mes chers collègues si nous en sommes là
c'est parce que les françaises et les
français sont totalement mobilisées pour
surmonter cette crise parce que depuis
le tout début il applique les gestes
barrière avec attention parce que depuis
que nous avons le vaccin il répond très
largement présents pour se faire
vacciner parce qu'ils appliquent avec
responsabilité altruisme les dispositifs
qui nous permet de freiner la
propagation du virus comme le pass
sanitaire par exemple si nous en sommes
là c'est parce que l'ensemble de nos
personnels soignants sont totalement
engagés dans cette crise depuis le tout
premier jour si nous en sommes là c'est
aussi parce que nous avons su prendre
courage et responsabilité les bonnes
décisions mes chers collègues
aujourd'hui au moment où nous allons
adopter son 11e textes législatifs
relatifs à la gestion la crise sanitaire
l'épidémie est sous contrôle sur la
quasi totalité du territoire national
elle demeure toutefois inquiétante dans
certains territoires ultramarins tout
particulièrement en guyane et en
martinique où l'état d'urgence sanitaire
sera prorogé jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021
dans ce moment que nous vivons l'envi
peut être forte de lever les dernières
contraintes qui subsiste de se dire que
tout cela est derrière nous et c'est au
fond ce que la plupart des groupes
d'opposition n'ont eu de cesse de
proposer tout au long de nos débats
ce n'est malheureusement pas le cas des
inquiétudes fortes persiste l'entrée
dans l'hiver les fêtes de fin d'année la
possibilité de connaître d'autres
variant la faiblesse
le départ de la campagne de rappel pour
la troisième dose de vaccination et cela
nous oblige aujourd'hui à demeurer
vigilants et à garder les outils qui
nous permettent de continuer à endiguer
la propagation du cobp id c'est ce que
le gouvernement nous propose avec
responsabilité à travers ce texte en
prorogeant jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022
l'existence du régime juridique de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire du régime de
la gestion de la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire régime sous lequel
nous sommes actuellement ainsi que de
ses outils tels que le passé iteere face
à cette réalité de la crise et notre
volonté d'agir pour les françaises et
les français je regrette les positions
largement politiciens des oppositions
qui sont aveuglés par leur volonté
d'être contre le président et contre le
gouvernement une attitude qui traduit en
écoute
une attitude qui traduit en réalité mes
chers collègues de l'opposition votre
refus d'agir nous avons entendu beaucoup
de conseils durant nos débats et de
demande de retrait des différents outils
de gestion de la crise sanitaire mais
quand il s'agit de prendre des mesures
difficiles et courageuse la réalité est
que nous nous retrouvons plus grand
monde pour agir en dehors des bancs de
la majorité pour notre part le groupe la
république en marche votera le
dispositif qui nous est proposée par le
gouvernement car il est proportionnel
stable et lisible
il est le mieux à même de nous permettre
de gérer la période qui est devant nous
nous ne donnons pas pour autant un
chèque en blanc au gouvernement
nous avons notamment renforcer les
dispositifs de contrôle parlementaire en
obligeant le gouvernement à produire
deux rapports d'étape qui seront suivies
de débats avant le 15 février le 15 mai
2022 et nous avons clarifié dans la loi
les critères sur lesquels le
gouvernement devra s'appuyer pour
prendre des décisions concernant la mise
en place ou la levée du pass sanitaires
et le juge pourra contrôler
l'application de ces mesures bien
entendu mes chers collègues cette crise
sanitaire nous n'en sommes pas encore
sortis le moment n'est pas à l'abandon
des outils sanitaire qui nous permettent
d'agir et d'endiguer ce virus suivent
une telle voie ce serait prendre le
risque de faire face à une nouvelle
vague épidémique particulièrement forte
ce n'est pas ce que les françaises et
les français attendent de nous notre
responsabilité aujourd'hui est de rester
vigilants notamment dans les territoires
la circulation du virus est forte ou
repart à la hausse dans les territoires
où le taux de vaccination est trop
faible ou ceux où les services de
réanimation sont au bord de la
saturation
mes chers collègues je vous le dis ne
nous trompons pas nos concitoyens
n'attendent pas de nous des divisions
politiciennes entretenu sur le dos de la
crise mes chers collègues au fond je ne
suis ici que me répéter mais nos
concitoyens attendent de nous que nous
agissions avec courage et responsabilité
que nous leur donnions de la visibilité
sur la manière dont cette crise est
gérée que nous leur garantissons que
nous sommes en mesure de continuer à
maîtriser cette crise sanitaire
à protéger leur santé à maintenir les
lieux de vie du quotidien ouvert à
garantir le parfait déroulement de la
période électorale qui est devant nous
c'est ce que les françaises et les
français attendent de notre part et je
sais que la majorité parlementaire au
moins sera au rendez vous de ses
attentes je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue elle la parole
est maintenant monsieur philippe
gosselin pour les républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur nous sommes réunis pour une
dernière lecture aujourd'hui parce
qu'après le vote d'une question
préalable le sénat a tranché le sénat a
trouvé que finalement tout ce débat de
ces derniers jours était une forme de
mascarade puisque les dés étaient pipés
le gouvernement comme la majorité
renoncer à écouter les arguments des uns
ou des autres preuve en est aucun
argument aucun amendement n'a été adopté
ces dernières heures ces derniers jours
on s'obstine on y va et voilà où nous en
sommes moralité aujourd'hui c'est un
texte qui fait fi de la notion de temps
et de responsabilité du parlement nous
allons en jambes et pendant plusieurs
mois et jusqu'à la mi et et 2022 le
parlement les élections législatives
présidentielle avant mais ça ne pose
aucune question à la majorité évidemment
nous allons aussi faire fi de la
territorialisation nous allons affirmé
un jacobinisme exacerbée nous
n'étudierons pas finalement les
solutions possibles dans telle ou telle
partie de territoire parce que le
gouvernement et la majorité ont décidé
de ne voir qu'une tête ce qui évidemment
regrettable nous faisons fi aussi d'un
certain nombre de questions sur le pass
qui ont été posées se passe ce qui n'est
pas obligatoire pour aller dans une
école et faire du sport mais quand on
revient en fin d'après midi pour les
jeunes pour les enfants notamment dans
une association avec le même ballon de
basket par exemple là il faut le pass ce
qui est ce pas ce qui est obligatoire
pour prendre le train mais qui ne l'est
pas dans le métro où on est collé les
uns sur les autres on n'y comprend rien
et vous refusé d'expliquer quoi que ce
soit on fait fi aussi du secret médical
qui se trouve vraiment aujourd'hui
abîmées contre l'avis du conseil de
l'ordre et au profit des établissements
scolaires voilà où nous en sommes et
vous osez monsieur le ministre nous
parler d'un texte d' équilibre c'est ce
que vous devenez de dire à l'instant non
c'est un texte totalement déséquilibrée
et qui en plus remet en cause nos
institutions oui sous la vème république
il y à bien une primauté de l'exécutif
nous le savons c'est une république
rationaliser mais de ce point de vue
force est de constater que le
gouvernement n'a pas hésité à exploiter
les moindres opportunités de l'arsenal
constitutionnel pour agir mais justement
en face de ces opportunités il devrait y
avoir oui il devrait y avoir le contrôle
parce qu'il est constitutionnel du
parlement avec celui de la loi or or
force est de constater que depuis le
même le mars mars 2020 et l'instauration
de l'état d'urgence le parlement n'a
cessé de s'effacer et même de renoncer
oui il n'a renoncé car jamais sous la
vème république le recours aux
ordonnances n'a été aussi des voiliers
120 et habilitations un record en 2020
sous la vème république
l' ordonnance est devenu le droit commun
de la législation une forme de confiance
aveugle de la majorité tout a été fait
pour aller dans ce sens le parlement
renoncent même à voter la loi c'est
l'exemple ici la prorogation jusqu'au 31
juillet 2022 en est l'illustration une
forme d'obstination méthodique de la
majorité une obstination déraisonnable
vote après vote il n'y a pas de clause
de revoyure que nous appelons de nos
voeux et même sacha ollier qui est
aujourd'hui plus royaliste que le roi
pourtant avec une partie de la majorité
il y à un peu plus d'un an estimé
nécessaire d'avoir cette clause de
revoyure autres temps autres moeurs
était il ya quelques mois autant dire
des siècles le parlement renonce donc à
contrôler on en a eu l'exemple encore au
mois de janvier dernier avec la mise à
mort il n'y a pas d'autre terme de la
mission d'information de l'assemblée au
profit d'une vague promesse de simple
débat en séance alors oui monsieur le
rapporteur oui nous aurons effectivement
au mois de février un pseudo débat qui
ne sera peut-être même pas suivi d'un
vote ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est bien le vote qui va être opéré
aujourd'hui et qui d'une certaine façon
donne une forme de pleins pouvoirs aux
je ne parle pas de dictature ce n'est
pas le terme évidemment non non je ne
parle pas de dictature nous le savons
tous nous le savons tous c'est en
conclusion sous la vème république
c'est la logique du fait majoritaire et
de nos institutions rationaliser depuis
cinquante-huit d'avoir des majorité
docile nous le savons tous mais plus que
jamais par vos agissements la vôtre et
servile au risque même d' abîmer nos
institutions à la crise sanitaire qu'il
faut légitimement traité à laquelle nous
devons tous nous attacher s'ajoute donc
une vraie crise démocratique réel aux
conséquences plus profonde plus sourde
que vous ne l'imaginez et il faudra en
rendre des comptes
merci
la parole est à monsieur bruno myle yens
pour le mouvement démocrate elle est
démocrate apparenté
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
les mots ont un sens alors oui après 18
mois d'état d'urgence difficile pour
tous les français nous sommes satisfaits
de passer de l'urgence à la vigilance
sanitaire
après l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui
étaient indispensables pour enrayer
immédiatement la propagation
dévastatrices d'une pandémie mondiale
après la gestion de la sortie de crise
sanitaire qui a notamment vu la mise en
place d'un pass sanitaire nous entrons
dans une phase de surveillance des
indicateurs nous en sommes là
aujourd'hui parce que notre pays a su
faire les bons choix ne vous en déplaise
et tirer rapidement les enregistrements
de ses erreurs et mettre en place une
boîte à outils efficaces si avec près de
70 % de personnes vaccinées la france
est l'une des championnes du monde de la
vaccination notre pays vient même d'être
classé 7e en termes de gestion de la
crise sanitaire dans les pays de l' ocde
nous ne pouvons envisager l'arrêt
complet des mesures que nous avons
adoptées jusqu'à présent le ministre de
la santé a rappelé les chiffres nous
constatons une augmentation de la
diffusion du virus en france d'environ
10% certes la situation est plus
alarmante dans plusieurs pays voisins
comme l'allemagne ou les pays-bas mais
nous devons garder à notre portée la
possibilité de mobiliser au delà du 15
novembre prochain les moyens de lutte
contre cette pandémie l'automne et
l'hiver nous le savons sont des périodes
particulièrement propice à la
circulation des virus respiratoires
comme lakovic 19 d'ailleurs 40
départements dans notre pays ont un taux
d'incidence qui augmente à nouveau et
dans certains territoires d'outre-mer
vous le savez tous la situation est
inquiétante
l'épidémie est toujours là et n'attend
qu'un relâchement de notes repart pour
déferler en une nouvelle vague dont nous
connaissons par avance les effets chers
collègues en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
nous avions adopté un texte équilibré
responsable et respectueux du rôle du
parlement le sénat à détricoter ce que
nous avions fait le mouvement le groupe
mouvement démocrate et démocrate
apparenté le regrette car avec ce texte
il s'agit de maintenir un cadre
juridique et des outils qui nous
permettront de déclencher chaque fois
que cela sera nécessaire le plus
rapidement possible et de manière
proportionnée toutes mesures utiles pour
protéger chaque française et chaque
français de lakovic 19 avant-hier dans
cet hémicycle nous avons entendu
certains de nos collègues de
l'opposition crié au déni du rôle du
parlement notre groupe a tout au long
des onze textes sur la crise sanitaire
que nous avons examinés veiller au
respect de nos prérogatives
la date du 15 novembre pour la fin du
régime de gestion de la sortie de crise
sanitaire c'est le groupe démocrate
qu'il a obtenus afin que le gouvernement
repasse devant le parlement pour
l'adoption d'un nouveau dispositif si le
contexte le nécessitent aujourd'hui dans
la droite ligne de l'avis du conseil
d'état et du conseil des scientifiques
nous pensons indispensable d'avoir un
cadre juridique jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022
afin de donner suffisamment de
prévisibilité et de lisibilité au combat
que nous devons mener contre cette
pandémie près visibilité et lisibilité
c'est laisser la possibilité au
gouvernement d'agir le plus rapidement
possible mais c'est aussi donner aux
représentants du peuple que nous sommes
la possibilité de juger du bien fondé
des décisions prises par l'exécutif dans
les quatre semaines qui suivent
cette prise de décision avec le recul
nécessaire à l'évolution de ces mesures
donc nous ne faisons pas filles du
contrôle parlementaire c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle avec la majorité
nous avons souhaité la remise de
plusieurs rapports échelonnées sur
l'ensemble de la période et notre
collègue philippe vigier au nom de notre
groupe a demandé au ministre de la santé
dans cet hémicycle un débat au sein de
notre assemblée en février prochain
ce débat nous l'aurons et chaque groupe
politique pourra s'exprimer juger si
l'action du gouvernement est pertinente
et efficace ce débat le groupe démocrate
le portera avec exigence et vigilance et
la vigilance qui s'imposent chers
collègues le mouvement le groupe
mouvement démocrate et démocrate
apparenté vote aura donc ce texte avec
la volonté de continuer de lutter
efficacement contre cette pandémie et la
conviction d'agir de manière responsable
et vigilante je vous remercie la parole
est à madame à la radio
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de commission monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous terminons
aujourd'hui d'acter la prorogation d'un
triple état d'exception et d'urgence
dans notre société pour les huit
prochains mois nous sommes confrontés à
une situation extraordinaire depuis 18
mois personne sur les bancs républicain
de cet hémicycle ne sous-estime cette
pandémie personnes sur les bords
républicains de cet hémicycle ne
sous-estiment la difficulté à y répondre
de la gauche à la droite de l'assemblée
au sénat nous avons fait maintes
proposition proposé menthe alternatives
des propositions proportionnée pour
répondre en ces temps de crise sanitaire
des propositions permettant de concilier
nos libertés la vie sociale et
économique du pays et les contraintes de
cette pandémie et pourtant vous avez
décidé de faire de ces débats dialogue
de sourds ou plutôt devrais je dire un
quasi monologue d opposition tant leurs
propositions ne vous intéressait pas
vous avez décidé de balayer tout
encadrement de l'action du gouvernement
dans son exercice du pouvoir mes chers
collègues quelle image renvoyons nous à
nos concitoyens alors que leur confiance
dans les institutions s'effrite je suis
d'une gauche de gouvernement une gauche
démocratique une gauche républicaine une
gauche qui a le sens des responsabilités
une gauche qui veille aux liens qu'elle
entretient avec ses concitoyens une
gauche qui ne peut tolérer le rôle que
vous donnez à la représentation
nationale la jurisprudence du régime
d'exception que vous créez n'est pas
banal elle est même inquiétante vous
êtes en train d'en créer dans les moeurs
de notre institution la possibilité de
proroger un régime d'urgence un régime
d'exception un régime qui donne une
carte blanche dénué de tout contrôle
parlementaire à l'exécutif à un exécutif
quand bien même le sénat s'y opposent
fermement et notre assemblée l'adoptent
d'une infime majorité je vous le
rappelle quand bien même le parlement
dans sa grande majorité s'est opposé à
votre texte ce régime d'exception est
devenu l'opium de cette majorité il vous
plonge dans une lente accoutumance à
inscrire l'exception dans l' équilibre
de nos institutions il vous a coutume un
régime un équilibre artificielle qui
outrepasse notre rôle de contre-pouvoir
comptez-vous mettre la séparation des
pouvoirs en suspens dès qu'une crise
bouleverse notre société vous octroyez
ici une habilitation à l'exécutif qu'il
peut être assimilée cas un blanc seing
un blanc-seing qui ressemble d'autant
plus à une abdication de notre rôle de
l'essence même de notre mandat de notre
fonction de représentant de la nation le
concours à la conception de la loi et le
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement par
ce texte notre assemblée se voit privé
de ses fonctions pendant huit mois par
ce texte la prochaine tête de l'exécutif
pourra user des dispositifs que vous
avez mis en place par la jurisprudence
de ce texte un exécutif prochain pour
aller plus loin dans les attaques contre
nos institutions que vous avez déjà bien
entamée ce texte est d'une inconscience
déconcertante et c'est pourquoi nous
allons déposer un recours auprès du
conseil constitutionnel
ce sera donc sans surprise et sur ses
fondements que mon groupe les députés
socialistes et apparentés s'opposera à
ce texte notre assemblée le parlement
est la garantie la légitimité de votre
action je vous le rappelle et ne vous en
déplaise le parlement est la garantie
d'une intelligence collective
représentatif de notre société que vous
ne cessez de dénier vous avez entamé
cette législature en habilitant le
gouvernement à légiférer en droit du
travail par ordonnance vous terminez
cette législature en lui accordant un
pleins pouvoirs en matière d'exception
je le regrette et je nous alertent
collectivement sur cette demande du
président macron aux candidats macron
qui ne veut pas de débat à quelques
semaines d'un scrutin majeur
merci la parole avant de donner la
parole à monsieur de mugron je précise
que à la demande de la république en
marché de la france insoumise il y aura
sur l'ensemble du projet un scrutin
public le scrutin est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale il
interviendra tout de suite près les
orateurs inscrits et la discussion
général monsieur houbron à la parole
pour le groupe agir ensemble merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues dès le début de la
navette parlementaire ici et au sénat
chacune et chacun savait hélas que nous
transférions ce texte en lecture
définitive
en vertu de notre constitution le
dernier mot revient à l'assemblée
nationale mais gageons qu'il aurait été
préférable sur ce type de texte que les
parlementaires se mettent à la hauteur
de l'unité nécessaire en temps de crise
et qui ne cherchent pas le coût
politique
nous sommes de nouveau à l'épicentre a
déploré hier le directeur de l' oms
europe lors d'une conférence de presse
en ligne
le rythme actuel de transmission dans
les 53 pays de la région européenne est
très préoccupant si nous restons sur
cette trajectoire nous pourrions voir un
autre demi million de décès dus aux
copines dans la région d'ici à février
at il affirmé
alors il aurait été confortable surtout
à l'aube d'échéances électorales de
déchirer le pass sanitaire de s'asseoir
sur les chiffres de santé publique
france qui affichent une reprise de
l'épidémie depuis plus d'une semaine de
territorialiser des dispositifs alors
que le seuil d alerte concerne 55
départements contre 32 il ya moins de 7
jours ou encore de balayer d'un revers
de main la nécessité de la troisième
dose pour les plus fragiles d'entre nous
l'est du continent est confronté à une
nouvelle vague et les cas explose au
royaume uni en belgique en allemagne 19
1702 cas quotidiens ont été enregistrés
en moyenne sur les sept derniers jours
un nombre qui n'avait pas été atteint
depuis fin avril
depuis le mois de mars 2020 le
gouvernement et la majorité ont pris des
mesures difficiles et n'ont jamais fui
leurs responsabilités
a priori impopulaire ces décisions ont
été acceptées par les françaises et les
français car ils ont compris
l'imprévisibilité qui conditionne
l'épidémie d'un virus inconnu et ont
remarqué que d'autres pays sont toujours
en état de paralysie le confinement la
campagne vaccinale le pass annie terre
tout devait être un échec une calamité
la fin de la démocratie mais citez moi
un seul de nos voisins européens dont le
parlement a débattu plus d'une dizaine
de fois sur ce sujet
citez moi un seul parlement dans le
monde qui a débattu cinq fois sans
compter la cmp en quatre jours sur ce
sujet et nous serions en autocratie en
dictature ou dans une séquelle régime
qui bâillonne l'opposition
chaque groupe parlementaire collègues
enfin
oui on écoute l'orateur merci monsieur
le président
chaque groupe parlementaire a pu
s'exprimer
chaque sensibilité a pu interpeller
alerter ou attirer l'attention des
membres du gouvernement parfois jusqu'au
petit matin
le groupe agir ensemble bien que
composante de la majorité avait des
exigences et ne souhaitait pas signer de
chèque en blanc
nous avons toujours été très soucieux
des dispositifs visant à renforcer le
contrôle parlementaire dans le cadre de
ce régime de gestion de la sortie de
crise sanitaire
à cet effet nous avons fait adopter un
amendement avec des groupes de la
majorité prévoyant l'encadrement du
recours aux passes tony terre en
précisant les critères sur lesquels le
pouvoir réglementaire devra se fonder
pour apprécier la nécessité de mettre ce
dispositif en place
notre groupe a aussi fait adopter un
amendement améliorer la protection des
données de santé des français dans le
cadre de la transmission des résultats
des tests pcr des pharmacies officier
cidep article supprimé par le sénat que
nous avons tenu à rétablir en nouvelle
lecture
la position du groupe agir ensemble n'a
pas changé sur ce projet de loi nous
voterons ce texte de concert avec les
autres composantes de la majorité
présidentielle nous faisons la part des
choses pour revenir à une solution
d'équilibré conciliant protection des
français et préservation des libertés
fondamentales
je vous remercie
merci la parole est désormais monsieur
pascal brindeau pour le groupe rugby et
indépendant
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
nos débats finalement aujourd'hui
on comme un air de déjà vu
certes les mots ont changé il ne s'agit
plus d'état d'urgence sanitaire il ne
s'agit plus de sorties de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire s'agit désormais de
vigilance sanitaire mais même si les
mots ont changé en réalité les actes
restent les mêmes et l'état juridique et
institutionnel dans lequel vous nous
avait contraints à entrer le parlement
l'exécutif et nos concitoyens depuis
mars dernier reste le même c'est à dire
que dans le droit commun et par seule
décision de l'exécutif
il est possible de prendre des mesures
certes pour la protection de la santé de
nos concitoyens ce que personne ne
conteste ici
mais sans que les prérogatives
constitutionnelles du parlement soient
respectés et ça c'est un des éléments
fondamentale du débat et du désaccord
que nous avons
l'autre
des accords
il est sur l' équilibre en fait des
mesures
que vous entendez prendre et la
temporalité
vous ne pouvez pas demander à un
parlement
de se dessaisir de ce pour quoi il est
fait et de ce qui fonde les équilibres
de nos institutions en enjambant une
élection présidentielle et des élections
législatives
personne ne sait aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs qui sera sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale au 31 juillet
prochain
on verra qui n'y sera plus
[Rires]
et en tout état de cause il est
indispensable que le parlement avant les
élections présidentielles n'ont pas
seulement puissent venir débattre sans
vote potentiellement de l'état sanitaire
à un moment donné c'est vraiment de
rediscuter et de voter à nouveau sur les
mesures qu'ils doivent ou qui ne doivent
pas être prises pour la sécurité
sanitaire de nos concitoyens un débat
qui me semblait indispensable
préalable à ce que vous nous proposez
mais qui n'existe pas je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure nous n'entendons plus le
président de la république s'est exprimé
sur la situation sanitaire dans le pays
nous n'entendons pas le premier ministre
exprime et non plus ni même le comité
scientifique qui appuyait toutes vos
décisions
pour savoir et expliquer à nos
concitoyens pourquoi l'épidémie re
connaît un rebond
pourquoi alors que la couverture
vaccinale dans notre pays
peut-être qualifiée de satisfaisante
même si elle doit encore progresser
pourquoi alors que des mesures gestes
barrières parce sanitaires parfois port
du masque obligatoire dans certains
départements pour les scolaires pourquoi
alors que toutes ces mesures qui sont
considérés par vous comme justes
efficaces
pourquoi est-ce que le virus connaît un
rebond il connaît un rebond en france
certes il connaît un rebond dans
d'autres pays
parfois de manière plus intense mais
pour autant personne ne sait dire ici à
cet instant si le virus restera sous
contrôle dans notre pays dans les
prochains mois ou pas
et ce débat là nous ne l'avons pas ce
débat là monsieur le ministre
vous ne nous apporter aucune
aucun élément scientifique
pour pouvoir justement juger de la
pertinence du maintien du pass sanitaire
dans certaines circonstances ou pas du
maintien d'autres règles
qui évidemment sont attentatoires aux
libertés nos concitoyens pour qu'ils
acceptent ces règles il faut qu'ils les
comprennent c'est un peu là aussi le
débat que nous avons depuis le début
depuis près de deux ans vous péché par
trop grande confiance en vous vous
pêchez aussi par incohérences vous
pêchez parce qu'à un moment donné vous
n'avez pas voulu territorialisée des
mesures là où elle était possible à
territorialisée ce que nous vous
demandions sur beaucoup de bancs de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
et aujourd'hui la confiance elle
n'existe toujours pas dans nos
concitoyens dans vos mesures est dans la
situation sanitaire et c'est une des
raisons fondamentales et majeures pour
lesquelles le groupe udi votera contre
ce texte
merci émeutiers brindeau la parole est
maintenant avec le paul molac pour
liberté territoire
à outreau président n'oblige à du
rigolet d'argent aux oreilles monsieur
ministre elle aime la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur
sans surprise dirais-je de nous
réunissons ce matin avec une navette
express entre l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat c'est donc notre assemblée qui
ce sursis sur ce sujet aura comme le
veut l'usagé le dernier mot
enfin je ne sais pas vraiment si c'est
le cas quand on voit que face à un
nombre conséquent d'amendements et
malgré des votes serrés ce texte soumis
par le gouvernement n'a bougé qu'à la
marge et cela également malgré l'écart
considérable qu'il y avait avec le texte
sorti du sénat aucun de nos arguments
n'aura donc été entendu que cela soit au
sujet de la territorialisation de la
clause de revoyure de la nécessaire
proportionnalité des délits et des
peines mais aussi du retour à la vie
normale en dehors de tout cadre
d'urgence le gouvernement avec sa
majorité préfère avancer seul le noeud
du problème est bien là pour le groupe
liberté et territoires nous maintenons
qu'à l'heure actuelle il est
envisageable de mettre fin à ce régime
d'exception dont le conseil d'état
considère que les mesures mises en
oeuvre sont efficaces pour faire face à
un désordre momentané mais ne sont rien
pertinentes pour des menaces pérenne
depuis le début nous avons été constants
dans nos prises de position s'il était
nécessaire de donner en mars 2020 les
outils pour endiguer la vague épidémique
nous avons refusé depuis lors de
conférer les pleins pouvoirs sanitaire
au gouvernement sans véritable contrôle
démocratique et un rapport ce n'est pas
un contrôle démocratique
cette épidémie est grave mais nous
répétons depuis le début que cette crise
que que l'exécutif a tort de s'enfermer
dans une logique verticale je le disais
l'union se décrète ne se décrète pas
elle se construit elle se construit
évidemment en acceptant les idées et les
volontés des autres d'ailleurs nous ne
comprenons toujours pas pourquoi il
n'est pas possible aujourd'hui de
procéder à la territorialisation des
mesures voilà donc un réflexe de
jacobinisme exacerbé où l'on considère
depuis paris qu'une mesure sera plus
efficace si on l'appliqué partout ou
presque sans tenir compte des avis des
élus de la population ou plus simplement
des réalités et situation sanitaire
locale si le taux d'incidence est aux
alentours de 50 en bretagne je rappelle
qu'il ya un an nous avions fermé les
bars et restaurants
lorsque ces derniers avaient dépassé le
taux de 250 alors que personne n'était
encore vaccinés je m'interroge par
ailleurs désormais sur la pertinence et
la fiabilité de l'étude du taux
d'incidence dès lors que les formes
graves et c'est heureux des maladies
dues au virus sont en constante baisse
d'ailleurs j'ajoute que si
l'instauration du passé à lithaire a eu
pour conséquence de faire augmenter le
nombre de vaccinations ce taux est
désormais de plus de 95% parmi la
population éligible dans de nombreux
départements français on se demande
alors quel est l'utilité de maintenir
cette mesure liberticide de manière
uniforme sur l'ensemble du territoire
nous avons constaté lors de la
commission mixte paritaire puis lors de
l'examen la nouvelle ses lectures
qu'aucune avancée n'était possible du
fait de la position inflexible du
gouvernement ce n'est pas faute pourtant
d'avoir été force de proposition que ce
soit du côté des oppositions à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat voir
certaines individualités dans votre
propre majorité et je sais que par
exemple au mois de mai cette majorité
avaient dit non à son gouvernement à
propos du passé ni terre que le passé ni
terre ne devait pas être utilisé pour
les actes de la vie quotidienne
malheureusement vous est vite rentré
dans le rang au mois de juillet dès lors
sans justification sanitaire majeur de
ceux du sud dispositif au contrôle
systématique de tous pour tous et
profondément attentatoire aux libertés
fondamentales
en effet le fait de devoir présenter un
document de santé personnel pour chaque
acte quotidien n'est pas anodin et ne
doit pas être pérennisée et si la
territorialisation des mesures est un
marqueur fort de notre groupe au même
titre que la défense des libertés nous
sommes également attachés à la
proportionnalité des peines et là encore
le compte n'y est pas nous regrettons
ainsi qu'en commission le dispositif
concernant l'augmentation des sanctions
en cas de fraude au pass and i ter est
été rétabli et on les trouve totalement
disproportionnée enfin à propos de
l'obligation de présentation du carnet
vaccinal des élèves aux directeurs
d'établissements
nous réitérons notre ferme opposition
sur une mesure qui avait fait l'objet
d'un accord avec le sénat et sur lequel
vous vous asseyez désormais le protocole
actuel donne suffisamment satisfaction
et nous refusons que des enfants
puissent être stigmatisés en raison de
leur statut vaccinal
le fait de donner les pleins pouvoirs
sans évaluation réelle de l'action menée
depuis mars 2021 2020 pardon or il y a
beaucoup à dire sur la gestion des
masques des tests et le choix du tout
vaccinal
donc oui les mesures doivent être
débattues voter et encadré c'est ce que
nous voulons c'est ce que vous refusez
nous le déplorons nous ne pourrons dans
ce cas pas vous accorder les pleins
pouvoirs et nous ferons évidemment un
concept un recours au conseil
constitutionnel
notre opposition à ce passe à cette
volonté de plein pouvoir est totale je
vous remercie merci à sa collègue la
parole est maintenant mam carline fiat
pour la france 1 fut mise
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
mercredi en vous écoutant nous avons
fait place à plusieurs incohérences
c'est pas la première fois évidemment
c'était les oppositions qui est
arc-boutée obtus tu ne voulais pas
comprendre voire pire les oppositions
irresponsables ne se rendrait pas compte
du danger du virus sérieusement vous en
êtes encore là revenons sur quelques
incohérences grâce au pass sanitaires et
à vos décisions la france serait la
meilleure élève et le taux très bas mais
dans le même temps ce n'est pas votre
marque de fabrique pour rien vous nous
dites qu'il faut maintenir le pass
sanitaire cas l'écart et augmente et
vous rendez les tests payant dans le
même temps comment peuvent-ils augmenter
si les solutions que vous avez proposées
sont si bonnes et que c'est pour ça
qu'on doit le maintenir
vous refusez la territorialisation pour
lever le pass sanitaire ce serait
ingérable selon vous mais vous
territorialisée déjà hexagone soignant
non vaccinés suspendu dans une période
où on manque cruellement de soignants
d'ailleurs nous vous avions prévenu dès
juillet que c'était la pire des idées
mais view territorialisées car manquant
de soignants en guyane pas de suspension
et en martinique après avoir gazé les
soignants et monsieur le ministre vous
passerez le message à monsieur le
ministre de la santé qu'il arrête s'il
vous plaît de dire que c'est faux nous
avons tous vu les images devant
l'hôpital alors oui ce n'était pas dans
l'hôpital évidemment car les personnels
et en os en matinée ne pouvait pas y
pénétrer mais munis de leurs tuniques et
de leurs blouses ils et elles étaient
vous en conviendrez facilement
reconnaissable non monsieur le ministre
on cuit vous avez gaz et les soignants
que vous applaudissez à 20 heures mais
ils ont gagné et les suspensions et les
suspensions sont levés bravo l alleud
ils pourront continuer leurs missions
dont on a énormément besoin
autres territorialisation le port du
masque des enfants à l'école selon
département et le taux d'incidence le
port du masque peut être levée pourquoi
ne pourriez vous pas faire de même avec
le pass sanitaire pas de réponse autre
incohérence et des moindres l'accès à la
vaccination non obligatoire des enfants
par les directeurs d'établissements
scolaires et pour quel motif parce que
selon la réponse de madame la ministre
bourguignon un enfant vacciné n'est pas
considéré qu'à contacter ah bon un
enfant vacciné ne peut pas être porteurs
asymptomatiques
un enfant vacciné ne peut pas
transmettre le virus rendez vous compte
de l'incohérence dangereuse de cette
décision donc on peut se retrouver avec
un gamin porter mais vaccinés qui va
continuer à aller à l'école et à
éventuellement continue à contaminer les
copains copines non on va refuser isoler
son camarade non vaccinés le tout sous
couvert des directeurs d'établissements
qui n'ont jamais rien demandé qu'ils
n'ont jamais réclamé cette somme
supplémentaire car ce n'est pas leur
tâche dois je vous rappeler que les
documents de rentrée scolaire sont
déclaratif que seuls les médecins
scolaires peuvent demander les pièces
nécessaires c'est à dire le carnet de
santé justifiant les vaccins
obligatoires
par contre toujours pas de classes
dédoublées toujours pas de purificateurs
d'air la ficelle est grosse ce n'est pas
en pondant ce genre d'idée inutile que
vous serez dédouaner de vos erreurs et
de vos inaction ce n'est pas parce que
vous prenez une décision ici inutile
soit elle que vous régler le problème ça
se saurait mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
nous avons tous proposé de nous
retrouver décembre janvier ou février
avant la fin de la séance ordinaire pour
faire le point refus de votre part ce
sera jusqu'au 31 juillet pourquoi 31
juillet nous ne savons toujours pas mais
ce sera comme ça sauf qu'il y a des
échéances monsieur le ministre qui peut
prédire les résultats des prochaines
élections qui peut laisser les pleins
pouvoirs un ou une inconnu sans
sourciller êtes vous si sûr d'être réélu
qu'emmanuel mâcon sera réélu et si
c'était quelqu'un d'autre il sera temps
de pleurer de dire comme à votre
habitude votre habitude on pouvait pas
deviner ça passera pas êtes vous devenu
si sûr de vous pour signer un chèque en
blanc un ou une inconnu réveillez vous
voyez le danger chers collègues parce
qu'il sera trop tard après avoir voté de
répondre penaud d'ici quelques mois on
ne pouvait pas deviner et si c'est un
blanc et si c'est un blanc seing
monsieur le ministre car pouvoir par
exemple confiner le pays et ne venir
devant l'assemblée qu'un mois plus tard
c'est un blanc seing je vais m'arrêter
là niveau incohérences j'aurais pu vous
en citer d'autres bien sûr mais limitée
à 5 minutes je vais me limiter en vous
prenant l'exemple de ces quelques
incohérences vous vous rendrez
facilement compte que vous n'avez aucune
bonne raison de continuer sur cette voie
si ce n'est pour choisir de mauvaises
décisions comme le comporte ce texte la
colère gronde alors vous serrer la vis
les voix s'élèvent alors vous museler le
peuple comme l'a résumé jean luc
mélenchon faute d'avoir réussi à être
convaincant vous punissez les non
convaincus vous pensez pouvoir sauver la
face en déployant la seule méthode que
vous connaissez la répression à croire
que votre seule stratégie c'est le chaos
avec vous c'est désormais le coup d'état
d'exception permanent pour nous c'est
non merci nous allons maintenant écouter
le président châtaignes qui va
s'exprimer au nom du groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
en pleine forme
opéra
seul président ce ministre chers
collègues malgré les oppositions
multiples le gouvernement persiste dans
son approche sécuritaire de la gestion
de crise et pérennise le choix d'une
politique autoritaire
prorogation du cadre juridique de l'état
d'urgence prorogation du régime
transitoire de sortie de l'état
d'urgence pour vocation de la
possibilité de mobiliser le pass and i
ter prorogation des dérogations au
secret médical vous vous obstinez à
vouloir conserver quoi qu'il en coûte
pourtant des draps de droit des pouvoirs
d'exception
attentatoires aux libertés fondamentales
et ce jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 le mandat
des manuels macron s'achèvera donc son
régime qui se soustraient aux processus
démocratiques habituel régime
d'exception qui ne s'achèvera pas à la
fin du mandat quelle inconscience un
régime dans lequel le président de la
république dans le huis clos du conseil
de défense dont les principales
décisions sont ensuite adopté par décret
du premier ministre
un régime qui renforce considérablement
les prérogatives de l'exécutif
accentue le déséquilibre du fonction de
marc de la vème république et transforme
toujours plus le parlement en chambre
d'enregistrement
en bref un régime dans lequel sont mis
en sommeil le débat démocratique et le
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
dans ce contexte nous réitérons notre
ferme opposition à la banalisation de
l'état d'exception nous alertons depuis
des mois sur le risque bien réel de
pérennisation de ce mode de gestion
gardons en mémoire chers collègues
gardons en mémoire qu'à la suite des
attentats terroristes de 2015 l'état
d'urgence sécuritaire a duré 24 mois et
ici la prit fin avec vous le 1er
novembre 2017 c'est lorsque le
dispositif hérité l'état d'urgence ont
été intégrés au droit commun par la loi
renforçant la sécurité intérieure et la
lutte contre le terrorisme
le conseil d'état rappelle à cet égard
dans son étude annuelle 2021 que sur les
six dernières années la france aura
passé la moitié en état d'urgence au
point que nous pouvons nous demander si
nous vivons perpétuellement crise ou si
ce cadre juridique est en voie de
devenir un mode de gouvernement
banalisée citation du conseil d'état
dans le même sens dans son avis du 5
octobre le conseil scientifique tient à
alerter je cite sur le risque d'une
banalisation du passani terre et des
mesures de contrôles associés alors que
la situation est apaisée aussi
réaffirmant nous solennellement notre
position à cette énième demande de
prorogation du dispositif d'exception
disproportionnée au regard de la
situation sanitaire actuelle vous nous
dites vous nous dites que le contexte
demeure encore incertain nous vous
répondons que nous nous sommes plus
démunis face à la pandémie et que la
poursuite de mesures d'exception ne se
justifie pas la vaccination massive nous
rapproche de l'immunité collective
86% de la population de plus de 12 ans
et désormais vaccinés 73 6 % de la
population totale un large éventail
d'outils est désormais disponible pour
vivre avec le virus gel masque gestes
barrières télétravail et j'en passe le
virus est mieux connue scientifiquement
et des traitements antiviraux actif par
voie orale comme le sar skovde deux sont
en cours de développement j'ajouterai
que la meilleure façon de nous protéger
contre le virus et de poursuivre la
campagne vaccinale au plus près du
terrain en prenant en considération les
inégalités territoriales dans l'accès
aux soins c'est sans sous-évalué le
phénomène de méfiance dans la parole
publique dans les territoires
d'outre-mer en particulier où l'épidémie
est la plus forte ou les systèmes de
santé sont les plus fragiles où le taux
de vaccination est le plus faible l'état
n'est pas à la hauteur ces propos
moralisateurs et condescendant n'ont
fait qu'envenimer la situation
enfin les élections présidentielles
législatives et la clôture de la session
parlementaire ne sont pas des arguments
recevables
pour projet des régimes dérogatoires du
droit commun jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 le
parlement est en capacité de se réunir
en urgence à tout moment il n'est donc
pas question de délivrer un blanc-seing
dans la des périodes électorales qui
s'annoncent la démocratie ne peut être
mise en parenthèse pour des raisons de
confort et d'agenda politique
déterminée nous voterons résolument
contre ce projet de loi malheureusement
en écoutant le rapporteur et les
orateurs de la majorité
nous venons de faire à nouveau le
constat que l'absence de colonne
vertébrale pouvaient rendre fiers mais
qu elle n'empêchait pas de rampes et
quand donc cadeau
quand on prend deux buts chers collègues
qu'elle dont il est victor hugo la nuit
feu se faire dans le monde moral et il
faut allumer des flambeaux dans les
esprits il n'est pas trop tard pour vous
de rallumer les flambeaux de la
démocratie que par défaut
un défaut merci à défaut nous saisirons
bien évidemment le conseil
constitutionnel merci
alors nous allons voter pour le texte
un vote à scrutin public a été annoncé
chacun a pu regagner sa place
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats
votants 208 exprimé 207 majorité 104% 18
contre 89 texte est donc adopté mes
chers collègues avant de poursuivre
notre 2 du jour nous allons nous
accorder deux minutes de pose de façon à
permettre aux uns et aux autres de
prendre leur place merci
[Applaudissements]
il ya plus deux rapporteurs que de
méchants
employés
la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle la suite de l'année